oh
m
bonsoir donc diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs
ce soir donc spécial linares avec et le
rolland je pousserai bonsoir stéphane
bonsoir à tous donc il s'agit d'une
émission tout à fait particulière y aura
pas d'analysé partie on vous a mis la
partie entre temps des qualifs en une
jolie partie d'ailleurs mais on ne
pourra pas la commande témoin puisque on
a beaucoup de contenu vidéo
oui effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
contenu puisque nous sommes allés à
linares en direct enfin nous sommes
allés en enril personnes c'est à linares
pour aller filmer et prendre des images
de ce super tournoi
et ça s'est avéré très productif puisque
nous avons les interviews de
pratiquement tout le monde pratiquement
tout le monde donc sauf viswanathan
anand le numéro 2 mondial qui a fait une
prestation bien dessous de son niveau
habituel puisqu'il termine alors ça ne
tourne un peu particulier le on va
peut-être d'abord dire le résultat final
puisqu'il termine dans le deuxième
paquet je veux dire eh oui il termine
deuxième paquet puisque avait que deux
paquets dans ce tournoi il y avait les
premiers et les derniers ils étayent
avec eux s'ils jouent alors quatre
derniers qu on l'a déjà dit la semaine
dernière ça la situation n'a pas évolué
depuis la dernière émission et deux
joueurs premier quart pauvres de
kasparov et vladimir kramnik voilà donc
piètre prestation d'un an disons qu'il
ne pouvait s'attendre à mieux donc il
était un peu déçu et il a estimé loi qui
n'avait rien à dire en fait oui tout à
fait suite après les mains de
sollicitations un an de ces restreint à
cette déclaration simple to say what
donc voilà pas de pas de commentaire en
revanche sur le chat de canal web
il y à jean-luc chavanon qui fait des
commentaires sur l'émission donc si vous
regardez l'émission en direct
connectez vous sur le chat et il ya jean
luc chavanon le maître international
cannois qui répondra à vos questions
pour la précision ce chat est disponible
sur le site de canal web donc si vous le
regardez ce site
l'émission pardon depuis un site
partenaire il y en a beaucoup et la
fédération française il ya tout est
évidemment il ya aussi la tour infernale
site est doté sport24 libération
évidemment libération jean-pierre
mercier annoncé que garry kasparov était
présent personne ce soir il s'est trompé
il n'est pas présent personne il
présente virtuellement
donc on va enchaîner tout de suite donc
par des images d'abord de ceux de ce
tournoi donc de linares avec donc un
petit clip de présentation qui fait un
petit détour de ce qu'on pouvait voir là
bas
vous
oh
donc voilà donc on a vu donc la salle de
jeu les joueurs qu est-ce qu on peut
noter deux spéciales dans cette salle de
jouer moi je crois qu'ils avaient des
colonnes oui effectivement la salle a
été pensé je dirais contre contre les
caméras puisque il y avait des colonnes
et il y avait des lumières qui est émise
dans le fond qui contribuerait à faire
des plans pas très joli mais enfin voilà
ce que vous avez pu voir c'est quand
même un bel événement voilà vont pas
tout à fait donc une salle dédiée au
spectacle mais du grand spectacle quand
même on a vu notamment alors un rituel
on peut dire l on l'a vu avec 1,06 et
kasparov c'est toujours le même
peut-être que comme tu le connais par
coeur ce rituel tu peux tu peux tout
faire oui alors kasparov arrive la
première chose qu'il fait c'est de
sortir la plaque de chocolat les seuls
quelques chocolats de sa porsche il la
pose sur la table
ensuite il enlève sa montre il la pose à
côté du chocolat et là le fameux
donc là je vais pas enlever le micro et
qui sonne et je sais pas ce qu'il en
advint peu sa cravate
il y manque de s'étouffer à chaque fois
et ensuite une fois ce petit cérémonial
terminé il est comme ça à fond à fond à
fond complètement ailleurs il est parti
donc on peut dire c'est pour une façon
de rentrer dans la partie au tout début
chacun sont chacun son truc et kasparov
a fait une mise en scène qui est cela
dit pas si intéressante et assez
amusante en tout cas voilà on a vu aussi
alexei shirov 1 donc on le cite ce sont
ces moments là vous pour les revoir
évidemment en différé donc à mieux
apprécier ce qu'on voit ce qu'on va
discuter sur alexei shirov cas une façon
tout à fait particulière de jouer les
coups oui et alors alexei shirov se
distingue de deux façons la façon dont
il joue ses coûts la façon dont il note
et on voit la troisième chose c'est la
façon dont il réfléchit qui est
totalement incroyable impressionnante
je sais pas quoi dire puisque et de
réfléchir en regardant soit le plafond
soit à droite ou à gauche
oui c'est l'animé il ne regarde jamais
jamais l'échiquier bon quand il le faut
son coup quand il regarde l'échiquier et
et là on a l'impression que c'est un
débutant
la façon dont ils attrapent la pièce on
a vraiment l'impression que c'est un
débutant la façon dont il note ses coups
ils se trompent régulièrement deux coups
sur sa feuille de partie et c'est
totalement stupéfiant de voir le numéro
quatre mondial ne pas réussir à faire
une feuille de partie
cible correct en intégralité voyez on a
aussi vu dans ce clip que si on regarde
bien moment donné avec ses shirov joue
un coup qui reprend en douceur en effet
dans l'hérault mais sur la case et on
sait qu'aux échecs et loire ans quand on
a touché une pièce eh bien il faut la
jouer effectivement on a c'est la
première fois que je vois ça - deux des
joueurs de ce niveau là que comme
l'excès shirov qui joue un coup et qui
finalement se rendre compte qu'ils
veulent c'est parce qu'on voit qu'il
voulait jouer et or viennent à pied sa
place il a enlevé le coup qui avait
préalablement noté sur la fin de partie
pour après finalement joué un
entrepreneur mais avec la même qui a
évidemment puisqu'il est obligé de jouer
cette pièce qu oui alors chacun son
analyse de cette situation on peut pas
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé le
cela dit shirov a pris son roi l'a
avancé est revenu en arrière après à
noter quelque chose sur sa feuille
ensuite à mon avis ils devaient
réfléchir à une proposition de nuls
puisque au coup d'après il a joué son
sens le même coup droit a proposé nul
qui a été acceptée par vladimir kramnik
donc en fait il a joué le même coup mais
avec une proposition nul en plus
quelqu'un en fait il avait deux
possibilités de pauvres sont rois
finalement il s'est rétracté au dernier
moment et il a eu un doute mais sa
première fois qu'on voit un joueur de ce
niveau un train depuis qu'on fait des
reportages reprendre comme ça un coup
qui a une fois que la pièce et a été
touché effectivement normalement dans la
pratique des grands maîtres une fois
qu'on a décidé de jouer un coup le
mouvement de la main n'a plus aucun
intérêt on s'est arrêté de travailler
tout simplement et on secoue c'est c'est
de la mécanique simple
alexei shirov lui même quand il est en
train d'achever son coût continue à
réfléchir c'est c'est du talent c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel en tout cas
voilà donc quand vous invite à revoir ce
clip et à faire attention à ces détails
on va passer maintenant une présentation
un peu plus en profondeur de l'événement
à linares avec une présentation plus et
donc de du lieu du tournoi et diagonale
qui vit donc à linares avant la dernière
ronde du tournoi et loi un très gros
tournoi a dominé par kasparov et kramnik
oui effectivement pour l'instant les
deux joueurs se détachent kasparov et
crame nick ont plus de chacun et les
quatre poursuivants sont ex-aequo donc
dernier ex-aequo malheureusement pour
eux à -1 pas l'envoyer derrière nous
donc c'est l'hôtel hannibal fameux hôtel
l'animal de linares minarets est une
petite ville où en moyenne ville on va
dire de 60000 habitants avec pas moins
de six clubs d'échecs j'ai vu ça dans
les journaux sportifs ce matin un
tournant qui suivit dans la majorité des
taux d
didier sportifs espagnols oui tout à
fait les échecs sont une tradition en
espagne ici à linares c'est plutôt la
tradition d'un seul homme c'est louis
sereine terreau qui est propriétaire de
l'hôtel devant lequel nous nous tenons
l'hôtel hannibal ii qu'il est
propriétaire de cet hôtel il est plus ou
moins multimillionnaire et il organise
depuis 20 ans déjà ce tournoi d'échecs
de linares
voilà donc résultats de cette dernière
ronde et aujourd'hui est donc reportage
complet de diagonale qui vit sur le plus
grand tournoi du monde
voilà nous sommes ici et loi maintenant
devant le corridor par lequel entrent et
sortent du joueur oui effectivement
c'est là l'objet de toutes les questions
du public de linares que ce passe-t-il
derrière ce fameux rideau orange qui
donc y ait dans le fond de la salle des
joueurs alors tout de suite on va
essayer de découvrir mais on va on va y
aller alors voilà ici donc c'est le
backstage
là où les joueurs viennent se recueillir
entre les coûts entre les coups même de
ceux de leurs adversaires ils viennent
donc ici pour se concentrer pour
échapper à la pression psychologique de
l'adversaire et s'asseoir ici dans ce
fauteuil prendre éventuellement un été
qui leur est servie ou un café et ils
ont ici devant eux la possibilité de
suivre donc leur parti sur ses écrans
télé qui reprennent donc les coûts sur
les différents échiquier voilà ici donc
dans cette partie de l'arrière scène
vous voyez devant nous les trois tables
ici d'analyser les joueurs donc après
leurs parties viennent ici commenté
cette partie analysée avec leur seconde
en est aussi on retrouve tous les
journalistes qui sont venus à linares il
y en a beaucoup notamment des russes des
hollandais des français évidemment des
anglais beaucoup d'anglais et d'espagnol
évidemment à foison
voilà ici au tournoi de linares c'est de
la haute technologie puisque il ya une
compagnie spécialisée qui vient pour la
télévision qui donne des images pour
canal plus espagne
canal+ france les chaînes locales
andalouse et ainsi de suite
donc derrière moi vous voyez nombreux
écrans de télé il ya trois techniciens
qui s'agitent frénétiquement pendant
toute la durée des parties pour produire
des images de qualité est alors à côté
donc nous allons nous déplacer vers la
deuxième grande partie de ce super
tournoi linares et nous voyons toute la
partie informatique donc là ce n'est
plus de la vidéo c'est de l'informatique
pour la retransmission des parties en
direct sur internet donc tout ici a été
prévu c'est vraiment un super tournoi
la technologie est au rendez vous tia
koné l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échec nous voilà dans la salle de jeu
du tournoi de linares et ici même sur
l'échiquier de garry kasparov pour cette
dernière ronde où ils affrontent l'inter
wisches manhattan allende donc vous
voyez ici les drapeaux la pendule et les
chics et donc théâtre des opérations
partie extrêmement chaude puisque si
garry kasparov l'emportent il gagnera
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
temps moi de linares et sinon ils
risquent d'être doublé sur la ligne
d'arrivée par vladimir kramnik affaire à
suivre
et compte rendu tout de suite voilà tout
de suite ces lois ça fait quoi de
s'asseoir à la table des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète
l'émotion difficile à extraire en finale
donc on a vu donc c'est bon c'est un
ancien hôtel donc pour la salle de
tournoi c'est pas une salle de spectacle
comme on peut le voir ailleurs mais donc
csn hôtel de prestige et on a vu donc
beaucoup de moyens on en a parlé dans
portal beaucoup de moyens arrivent et
c'est vraiment l'espagne vit à l'heure
des échecs oui oui oui il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens qui viennent voir ces
matches l'espagne vit bon on ne peut pas
non plus dire au rythme du tournoi mais
on sent quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont là pour qui aime bien
qu'ils aient bien les échecs qui compare
ça un peu une feria qui aime bien le
centre cas sur l'échiquier
alors qu'on n'a pas vu c'est la salle de
presse vous pouvez noter qu'il y avait
zen de journalistes de tous pays
angleterre est comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure est donc à ferrer sur internet
et loire avec dunks leur portable pour
mettre à jour des sites internet pour
leurs transmissions des parties ou en
tout cas envoyé des articles en temps
réel leurs différents journaux
respectifs
oui il était extrêmement nombreux ils
étaient vraiment de tout pays
bon effectivement la retransmission des
parties en direct a été bien effectuer
les comptes-rendus était bas et et
multinationaux il y en avait vraiment
partout partout ce tournoi étant le
clairement le plus fort tournoi du monde
le plus fort tournoi de l'année tout le
monde est là tout le monde est venu et
les comptes-rendus aller à plein régime
voilà donc compte-rendu on continue et
maintenant on va rentrer dans le vif du
sujet puisque maintenant on va voir une
flopée l'interview de très haut niveau
oui alors on va faire un par un tous les
joueurs effectivement un hand on ne l'a
pas on a déjà dit qu'il n'avait rien à
dire sur sa prestation
rappelons qu'il a été dernier il y avait
trois joueurs ex-aequo dernier avec lui
et donc on va peut-être commencer par
l'un d'entre eux alors on a décidé de
commencer dans l'ordre inverse du
classement elo donc on commence par le
champion du monde de filet qui se trouve
être le moins fort au classement elo
mais qui est quand même assez fort c'est
alexander kalichman international
tchèque news in the fall of animals
hôtel linares gouverneur with the ball
championne fideua jason alexander
kalichman lots soleil au score final
immanence one and very strong tonight
you satisfied with the result anglicane
un match en moins de bêtes abattues par
les lecteurs
et à 200 gourdes cherche un match tous
guéris kasparov en de sauviat ciolek iqw
louise garry kasparov et trois villes
importantes match fou une veste on a
nantes au just like aux employés de new
fabris 90 4 à 2 à just came un problème
au dos
tout est en couple est formé à l'école
de voile à alexander qui vit termine
avec une note d'humour et la vive la
france
ils étaient contents de la défense
française qui l'avait utilisé dans ce
tournoi oui effectivement c'était la
dernière question de cette interview
c'était comment cette est il préparé est
ce que ça a été difficile et à ça il a
répondu il est revenu sur son match
contre peter l'écho en janvier il a
expliqué que la cause de sa défaite
était simplement qu'il n'a pas su
répondre aux coups un e 4 et que là par
contre il est totalement satisfait il a
effectivement perdu une partie et que
cette défense française contre hollande
mais c'était par l'excès d'optimisme
puisqu'il a joué pour le gain la
situation dans le tournoi était la
suivante il était 3e il a vraiment joué
pour le gain du tournoi il a essayé
d'être à de rattraper
kasparov et krainik bon ça a tourné à
bombay par un drame mais ça a tourné à
une défaite assez c'est joli et seidel
donc voilà pour la question de la
préparation est donc vive la france
puisque la défense française a tenu le
coup autant que facile donc un
actionneur kalichman finalement plutôt
content de son résultat puisque comme il
le dit dans cette interview
donc le public en tout cas les
observateurs s'attendaient après sa
défaite cuisante de budapest comme iliad
est lui-même s'attendait plutôt à ce
qu'ils ne fassent quasiment pas de point
en moins de 2000 points ou 1 point c'est
ce que si c'est ce qu'ils se disaient
loin oui effectivement alors
y'avait des statistiques dans tous les
sens je n'irai pas jusqu'à aller enfin
gilles repas jusqu'à dire qu'ils avaient
des boucs bookmaking des bookmakers
anglais qui ont parié sur sur kalichman
à un point sur 10 mais effectivement on
attendait quand même que ça soit très
très difficile cependant il est assez
satisfait de son jeu il dit que ça
aurait pu être mieux qu'il aurait pu
faire mieux
mais quand même qu' il y là il a bien
joué et que pour une première expérience
puisque c'est la première fois qu'il
joue un tournoi de ce niveau là il s'en
est pas mal sorti donc il est assez
content de lui et à ses contenus y
compris de son match contre garry
kasparov ça parce que ça a été en fait
on tourne on y avait des mini-matchs
puisque chacun des joueurs rencontrés
les deux autres avec les blancs riz avec
les noirs et finalement il fait nul avec
le numéro un mondial ce qui est quand
même une bonne performance et qui montre
que son titre de champion du monde des
idées n'est pas un n'est pas totalement
usurpée oui effectivement il a fait deux
nuls contre garry kasparov m'ont
effectivement plus est au coeur de la
polémique puisque le garry kasparov
remet complètement en question ce
championnat du monde fis des dons
qu'alexander kalichman là bas était
représentant de la fidh est entre
guillemets puisque les champions du
monde de cette institution
effectivement il a fait deux nuls contre
kasparov donc la fille d l'honneur est
sauf
il est satisfait et en plus il est
surtout satisfait de son match contre
peter l'écho puisqu'il avait cet effet
atomisé
proprement janvier sur le score jeudi
récents commentaires de quatre et demi
un ennemi ou 3 1 trois victoires à zéro
surtout la victoire à zéro et là il a
réussi à gagner le mini match un point
et demi à 0,5 c'est à dire qu'un nul il
est totalement content de ça donc
finalement on peut dire que
ce tournoi c'était un peu l'inconnu
souchon a peut-être l'attraction de ce
tournoi c'était pendant s'étaient
qualifiés on s'attendait à devoir sans
résultat c'était une des inconnues
intéressante de ce tournoi il démontre
que peut-être des joueurs effectivement
qui sont moins bien classé au classement
elo n'ont pas la possibilité de faire
ces tournois du top du top et qui sont
fermés où on voit toujours les mêmes
joueurs entre amis que shirov kasparov
et quand un joueur de ce niveau là peut
jouer mais il est loin d'être ridicule
oui alors notamment
c'est le système du classement elo
puisque là il termine dernier du tournoi
mais il gagne 10 pour l eau quand même
donc effectivement s'il avait l'occasion
d'en jouer plus on peut supposer qu'ils
arriveraient atteindre ce cercle fermé
des joueurs qui pourraient commencer à
rester dans le cercle a joué avec eux et
à ce moment-là intégré intégrer cette
élite mondiale qui n'est pas accessible
facilement en tout cas donc tout est la
remise en question tout simplement du
classement elo qui est enfin dont la
formule est un peu statique est tout
simplement sans peut-être même occasion
de classement elo et on a vu aussi une
polémique à linares qui a surgi la fin
comme tout cas donc cramique kasparov et
à égalité
ça n'a plus trop de temps d'en parler de
la semaine dernière dans l'émission de
la semaine dernière puisque ça s'est un
peu libérée le lendemain dans les
journaux mais cette polémique il dit ce
type de tournoi mais voilà on arrive à
des possibilités de comme ça deux
ex-aequo puis derrière trois ex-aequo 4
même 4 ex-aequo ont fait route à la
troisième place ex-aequo donc un tournoi
qui financèrent tout le monde et on n'a
pas le suspense qu'on pourrait avoir si
on avait des matches à élimination alors
c'est peut-être aussi une remise en
cause de ce type de tournoi qui nivelle
peut-être le niveau des joueurs
je ne sais pas si ça nivelle le niveau
des joueurs en tout cas effectivement la
possibilité de terminer premiers
ex-aequo et est possible donc
effectivement ça ça tranche pas quoi
c'est pas net
la preuve c'est que la garry kasparov et
chroniques son premier ex-aequo et
et donc ont tout partagé tout partagé
ils ont partagé le trophée les titres
l'honneur la gloire et tout ce qu'on
veut mais personne n'a gagné linares
2010 ce qui est quand même un petit peu
dommage
ouais donc peut-être une première
revanche tout cas la polémique est née
en espagne et ils ont regretté qu'il n'y
ait pas de match de départage notamment
peut-être en partie rapide pour
départager les joueurs à la fin chose
qui a été évoqué d'ailleurs un autre
kasparov et chroniques ils y ont
réfléchi pendant une demi heure un peu
plus je crois oui une consultation dans
leur dans la chambre de vladimir kramnik
enfin on va pas faire du people ici mais
donc là je le résultat de cette de cette
consultation je dirais amical a été que
personne ne voulait quitter linares avec
une mauvaise image avec une mauvaise
impression en tout cas effectivement
celui qui aurait lancé la pièce sur la
mauvaise phase aurait eu quand même une
désagréable surprise ça aurait pas été
faire comme ils disent
après dix rondes après un tournoi
acharné lutte assez féroce de terminer
comme ça avec 1 pile ou face
pas de francs c'est dire donc un tout
cas kalichman jette un pavé dans la mare
pose des questions et on peut lire bravo
parce que ce n'est pas facile il était
seul put finalement contre 5 puisque
c'est aussi cinq joueurs en face de lui
qui voulait démontrer qu'ils étaient
clairement plus fort que lui ils n'ont
pas réussi à le faire
alexander kalichman c'est la bonne
performance de ce tournoi voilà donc on
passe maintenant des à son bureau son
bourreau du mois de janvier mais qu'il a
du coup a eu un retour de bâton c'est
peter l'écho
magna international chez news we are now
with people & co inc fondamentaux
blinoise c'est à l'hôpital que youtube
play no game against garry kasparov un
dieu ma note je te mets que joe white
position' look promising for your heart
of youth can you give some commons
abbott vice game 6 et des formes de
double oui en or by force de la game en
2009 soit en dessous de 100 winwood
gamecube yves ce qui pose un veston ne
m'entende vis results that is off comme
le note as good as nadine of energy
making fuck you just one à 9,2 m
les blacks dans les espaces musicaux
donc la loi un peter les coûts toujours
très prolixe et à chaque fois une
interview il aime bien parler non
effectivement est d'ailleurs you're
welcome nous sommes bien venu pour
l'interviewer c'est vrai que c'est
toujours assez agréable il a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire il est
débordant d'énergie
la première chose il a commenté sa
partie contre kas parents fous où il
aurait pu peut-être l'emporter
oui là c'est au conditionnel puisque
kasparov est quand même très très fort
en défense disons qu'il a pris un
avantage dans l'ouverture il a réussi un
peu déstabilisé la célèbre night of de
garry kasparov
mais ensuite
bon ok ce pare-feu l'iaaf qui s'est
révélé être en fait un excellent coup
mais surtout les joueurs pensaient que
c'était une gaffe mais après l'avoir
joué il se trouve que les ressources
sont apparus il n'avait pas prévu dit
oui voilà c'est en fait ça a dépassé un
peu le ce qu'ils avaient vu les déchets
chacun des joueurs et icbc trouvé que
kasparov s'est retrouvé dans une
situation tout à fait raisonnable car
les corps commencent à être mal autant
et la nuit là donc était été conclue
donc peter l'écho fait nul contre
kasparov facile c'est quand même pas un
mauvais résultat
ouais c'est pas un mauvais résultat
alors il analyse sa performance au
tournoi comme finalement assez moyennes
et surtout ils vont effectivement assez
moyenne et il explique se sont
affrontées en demi teinte mais pas si
mauvais que ça finalement ce
retournement là mais il explique par le
fait qu'il a beaucoup joué avant est
telle qu'il avait perdu un peu d'énergie
oui tout à fait oui effectivement il a
dit trois quatre mois non-stop bling ça
veut dire qu'il n'a pas arrêté de jouer
pendant trois ou quatre mois
c'est vraiment beaucoup ça veut dire
qu'ils jouent et qu'il a plus le temps
de se préparer il a pu le temps de
chercher des améliorations dans les
ouvertures et il a un manque d'énergie
très clair et donc à cause de sa cause
de ce manque d'énergie n'a pas réussi à
conclure les parties les positions
gagnantes qui l'a obtenu et à ce niveau
là ça pardonne pas c'est à dire que
quand on fait des cadeaux à des joueurs
du top 10 mondial
et bien il n'en font pas et donc ça se
ressent sur le résultat final et finit à
- ça il a aussi dit quelque chose
d'intéressant sur sa partie comme calife
man où il a perdu à la maison
en fait oui c'est ça contre lequel il
mène il n'a pas eu de chance il est
tombé dans une préparation du champion
du monde filet il a pas réussi à s'en
sortir tout simplement c'était une
défense de noël
le khalife comme on l'appelle dans le
milieu chilien le khalife a déroulé une
préparation absolument fantastique et
simplement plus tard les cônes n'a pas
pu résister et donc là il est revenu sur
sur cette partie là puisqu'on lui a
demandé ce qu'ils comptaient faire
contre chronique avec les noirs et
vladimir kramnik joué exactement les
ventes que qu'alexander califano contre
la grande toile de pieter l'écho et il a
dit simplement qu est la cause
principale de cette défaite contre
qualif 27
cette mauvaise préparation était due au
fait qu'il avait simplement jouer une
sous arm une sous variantes qu'il ne
connaissait pas très bien et que donc
entre chronique qui reviendrait à dans
sa variante fétiche ça donne bien
solides de l'actuel voilà je crois que
c'est tout à peu près ce que peter rien
que nous à nous a raconté n'était
finalement pas si mécontent de son
résultat avait dit que ce serait
bénéfique au futur disons il a surtout
dit que maintenant il voulait se reposer
la question est ce que tu veux analyse
était parti tu veux te reposer et hino
et je veux me reposer mais non je ne
veux pas analysé du tout je suis
fatiguée maintenant je vais aller me
reposer donc si on suppose qu'il est
reparti à budapest et là qui va prendre
une bonne semaine de vacances sur les
bords du danube et on devrait le
retrouver je crois à sarajevo où je
crois d'ailleurs on peut le lire
il me semble non je suis pas sûr qu'on
fait qu'ils n'ont plus tard et qu'on ne
joue pas à sarajevo en tout cas on peut
le dire quand même moi je me trompe
élite et l'année dernière à sarajevo
on m'a quand même l'annoncé c'est qu'on
a appris que donc etienne bacrot était
invité au super tourne à sarajevo en mai
il est super tournoi puisqu'il aura
quand même rires kasparov cramique
shirov morose évident qu'elles vendent
ils sont ils sont tous très forts ils
sont tous là ça va être vraiment super
tournoi est là notre jeune mascotte
nationale à etienne bacrot champion
france plus jeune champion de france de
tous les temps plus jeunes grands
maîtres également 17 ans va avoir fort à
faire mais enfin bon qu'il aurait donné
gagnant contre anatoli karpov
on sait pas pourtant bien réussi à tenir
contre le champion du monde depuis 15
ans donc contre la légende vivante
d'anatolie karpov et là une prestation
très difficile parmi les joueurs du top
mondial à sarajevo à partir du 16 mai
voilà en tout cas un qui sera prise en
charge et vous c'est sûr c'est sur off
est donc maintenant une interview
d'alexei chien off
des gones à l'international chez news
winnezeele hannibal with alexei shirov
lots what can you give ceux qui pensent
qu'ils moment historique en si bonne
forme
ni personne personal staff des voix soit
enfin voir tim burton chemistry of fate
voilà avec ses six robes donc il ya bien
confirmé sa participation à sarajevo
donc à nice et shirov qui était troublé
par d'autre part des parts des thèmes
non échiquéen en fait oui effectivement
c'est la coupe est un peu dans sa
préparation puisqu'il est maintenant
père de famille il a une petite fille
depuis quatre mois et donc ça ça
effectivement ça prend du temps ça prend
de l'énergie et puis on pense un peu on
pense plus à son enfant qu aux échecs ça
semble logique même pour ses joueurs
d'exception alors qu'est-ce qui nous a
dit d'autre notre ami nous a expliqué
son
son tournoi en fait il est mal parti il
faisait faire un point et demi sur deux
et il a fait deux gaffes dans les deux
premières rondes et ce qui fait qu'il a
mis un demi point sur deux donc mauvais
départ et ensuite ils avaient du mal à
se reprendre à se remettre dans le
tournoi est ils étaient dans une
mauvaise forme globale dans ce tournoi
et contre les meilleurs joueurs du monde
ça pardonne pas effectivement il ya
beaucoup de respect en tout cas pour
pour les adversaires
parmi ces joueurs souligné jeu ont
enchaîné sur la sur sa forme ou
situation unique il n'était pas
président mais casey et nous on
s'attendait en fait c'est parce que vous
faites qui se prépare vraiment spécial
pour linares donc on la dernière enchère
offre super forme peut effectivement
c'était c'est pour ça que je les poser
cette question pourquoi il n'était pas
méchante c est en fait pour des raisons
diverses et variées mais c'était pas
spécialement pour pour se préparer pour
le tournoi de linares donc finalement il
y perd cinq points 0 mais il dit lui
même ça aurait pu être pire
ouais et donc qu'il allait enchaîner sur
il son équipe d'entraîneurs
il est venu avec reach agof le joueur
letton c1 c'est un jeune qui promet je
pense qu'il doit avoir de 1550 qui doit
travailler comme un fou puisque on
n'arrive pas dans l'équipe d'un top d'un
top mondial comme ça et effectivement
pour ce tournoi exceptionnel il a fait
venir un supplémentaire
remplaçants un bonus valérie salov quand
même ex je pense qu'il était quart de
finaliste aux demi finalistes des
candidats est 3e on est à l'étroit mais
mondial au classement est longue donc
valérie salov est venu c'est un bon ami
de chirac il est venu pour l'accompagner
ils ont fait du très bon travail
analytique les seconds en ont très bien
travaillé pour l'excellent shirov mais
ça n'a pas suffi pour pour vaincre en
fait ça sent mauvais passage sa mauvaise
forme enfin schirrhoffen continue quand
même à mettre le feu
sur l'échiquier c'est quand même le
joueur dans le tournant là qu'il ya le
style peut-être le plus original
oui c'est un joueur explosif un peu
comme le titre de son livre fire on the
world qui veut dire je mets le feu à
l'échiquier en fait donc c'est vraiment
toujours il est toujours à l'affût des
positions complexes
il a un style
vraiment tranchant et assez joli donc là
on a fait le tour en fait des quatre
perdants si on peut dire ou des quatre
troisièmes du tournoi
on va maintenant passer au 2o de gros
morceau une loi de ce tournoi c'est à
dire les deux co wenger dans l'ordre
donc entre vladimir kramnik et donc
garry kasparov l'a dit mercredi que pour
une fois très heureux de répondre à une
interview
oui oui vous l'a dit mercredi que la
avait le sourire il était très content
très content très satisfait normalement
c'est pas toujours facile d'avoir les
interviews de notamment vladimir kramnik
qui n'est pas si facile mais là il était
vraiment ravi de répondre à nos
questions et ça a donné une belle
interview que qu'on vous invite à
découvrir ici
l'international tchèque newsweek
analytical swiss garry kasparov
in fact and expecting mistake of
kasparov twins au gameplay
01/12 games week où des manèges tro
breiz défense position ça tu as to his
first and for players in the same groupe
last nicholas tu so you are completely
first i call un des oiseaux qui chantent
en playback guerre touchait le mapping
qui fait écho au point de compléter
qu'au tie-break connaît tout dépité
ce serait de cinq ans de hockey et gagne
ou success for you into my player is all
in my shoes en interne à nantes
six matches botte de lionel stoneham en
ue planes sarajevo mais bin dortmund
groupe f aux attaques mais de hockey
vladimir kramnik funk you want me to
life the green town
donc voilà donc moi j'ai juste été sous
le charme de ce lundi marc ramini en
pleine forme tout à fait heureux d'être
là et il rayonnait à la fin du tournoi
il était très très heureux d'avoir
réussi cette performance exceptionnelle
oui effectivement on sent encore
beaucoup de respect pour garry kasparov
puisqu'il déclare que c'est un honneur
d'être premiers ex-aequo et gary et que
c'est quand même la première fois depuis
un an que gary partagent la première
place tout simplement puisqu'il a
l'habitude de gagner tout seul et de
loin oui alors donc
la dîmière cramique qui me disait donc
notamment qu'il allait jouer le tournoi
de monaco qui a lieu actuellement
oui tant des courses moment un peu je
dirais la récréation des top des tops
joueurs puisque ça compte pas pour le
classement elo ils vont donc là-bas très
tranquille joutes des semi rapides et
josé partie à la bulle
c'est à monaco que c'est sympa donc
c'est vraiment le tournoi plage exact en
appel alors qu'est ce que nous dit
cramique d'un intéressant dans cette
interview donc maintenant sur le tourne
à linares sur sa performance
oui alors effectivement il ce qui nous a
dit un petit peu c'est
bon sur le tournoi c'est ça il est très
content d'avoir terminé premiers
ex-aequo pour l'histoire de départage il
a dit ce qu'on a dit en fait en
introduction c'est que il voulait pas
que quelqu'un parte avec une mauvaise
impression de linares alors il a quand
même souligné le point de règlement qui
était que dans ce cas vraiment ultime
qui s'étaient jamais vus auparavant donc
d'égalité parfaite entre deux joueurs et
fait exactement même nombre de deux
points c'était le tirage au sort d'une
pièce qui avait décidé du vainqueur du
tournoi
oui oui tout à fait donc le fameux
tirage au sort ils n'ont pas voulu de ce
tirage au sort est donc finalement les
organisateurs ont accepté d'aider
clarico vainqueur c'est qu'enfin quand
même un peu contraire à 7
cet esprit espagnol de trancher toujours
et d'avoir un champion oui mais franche
et getafe et donc voilà l'heure sur son
jeu je lui ai posé la question pourquoi
est ce qu'ils jouaient très bien les
tournois et très mal les matchs très mal
entre guillemets bien entendu puisque la
nouvelle chronique ne jouent pas très
mal il faut quand même le dire mais en
match il a des résultats un petit peu
moins beau moins bon tout simplement
mauvais il a perdu contre shirov il a
perdu contre kamski
problème en contrat demande aussi en
gros il perd la majorité des matchs qui
joue pourquoi ce qu'il sait en tournoi
il est toujours impérial royal toujours
en 2e ou 1er ex-aequo même et pourquoi
machi ça marche pas et bien sa réponse
est simplement très simple il n'aime pas
les matches je trouve ça ennuyeux de
voir toujours la même tête il est pas là
pour lui n'est pas là pour se battre on
quelqu'un en fait il est là pour jouer
différentes ouvertures différents styles
de jeu il est là pour jouer aux échecs
et non pas pour entrer dans une logique
qui est infernale comme les matchs
kasparov car preuve de moscou anna
j'extrapole puisqu'il n'a pas dit dans
l'interview mais mais en gros c'est ça
que ça veut dire vrai ils s'ennuient de
jouer contre le même adversaire en effet
les leviers que sont vertueux également
et tout ça ça l'ennuie dont il joue
beaucoup bien en tournoi c'est c'est un
des meilleurs joueurs de tournois au
monde évidemment
et je pense que c'est à peu près tout ce
qu'il a dit il a dit quand même qu'il
pense que dans le futur
ils jouent plus de matuidi son
expérience a matché pas s'élever aussi
et que dans le futur s'il va jouer plus
de matchs il pense que quand même il va
arriver à réussir à matraquer plus d'un
mois je vais tout à fait donc voilà donc
très jolie performance donc de vladimir
kramnik tu te disais aussi eloi est
peut-être mal revoir évidemment dans
l'est tout à l'heure parce que on avait
pondre dans l'interview kasparov
mais est utilisé que peut-être avec le
résultat devait quand j ai su linares
kramnik est en train de passer devant un
angle voyez cramer qui est en train de
prendre l'aventage sur un an puisque ici
ils font un point et demi d'écart ça
correspond quand même à 15 points elo
puisqu'ils ont le même classement donc
au prochain classement vraisemblablement
cramique commencera à grappiller à
manger un petit peu riche manhattan à
londres et est donc se retrouver en fait
clairement deuxième enfin plus ou moins
clairement puisque évidemment c'est
quand même question de forme toujours
question de moment question d'instants
est pour l'instant vladimir kramnik joue
mieux au kitsch manhattan annonce a
certes c'est un fait
alors peut-être un match kasparov
kramnik pour l'instant on parle plutôt
d'un match qui espèrent enfin on doit
donc on verra en tout cas maintenant on
est là c'est loin le plus important je
pense aujourd'hui de ce que la première
fois qu'on va la voir l'indépendant il a
tous eu déjà je crois qu'il ya un lapin
qu'on n'avait pas déjà eu avant dans
cette date ce panel d'interview mais là
c'est la première fois c'est le king
garry kasparov c'est très difficile de
la voir et loi je crois que on a eu du
mal
oui effectivement après quatre mois de
harcèlement de son manager enfin bon on
va pas trop en dire non plus on va pas
vous désirez vous donner les secrets
pouvoir l'interview de garry kasparov
mais c'est très très difficile et l'a
donc en exclusivité pour diagonale il a
accepté de répondre à quelques questions
voilà le king
il souffre encore de le faire
wahou 15 matinée venir 6 institute of
one with the best way et stx belle fanny
libert skweres dessinée historique la
signature probable favorables aux pass
qui te vendent leur corps
international chez news world with the
king garry kasparov hellot sau your
chair la dmr chronique et linares de vie
casée
rock and you get motivation stylo à
bille cinéaste dis pas pour vous mais à
chaud
ok computer openly prenantes
l'afficheur lac à paul mccartney 5
points
tous fouillés du boutis j 3 mois étant
mort factory fonds next a à toutes vos
meilleurs tubes yebo équipe
voilà donc gars kasparov qui parle de
lui à la troisième personne et lois
telles jules césar
effectivement en direct star of à la fin
donc ses vues de l'extérieur est en fait
j'espère qu'il garry kasparov donc en
parlant lui arrivera à développer
beaucoup de jeu d'échecs donc une cause
à ses nobles
alors revenons rapidement sur les autres
on va revenir sur tous les points sont
les points vite voilà donc le premier
extrait que vous avez vu c'était pas de
nous il expliquait simplement qu'il
était le meilleur joueur du monde
en gros dans les grandes lignes c'était
ça et que la fidh et avait été créée
pour déterminer qui était le meilleur et
que maintenant ça partait un peu comme
dans la boxe c'est à dire que la fille
d'eddie que le champion du monde sait
qui elle veut
lorsque le gard à 40 ans que le champion
du monde c'est savoir qui est le
meilleur joueur du monde et que bien
beau mais man 2 ensuite son analyse pour
plus ou moins le prétendant
pour le détrôner c'est à dire le numéro
deux mondial qui est le meilleur joueur
actuellement il dit que le tournoi li na
reste c'est un bon test
c'est un beau tournoi pour dire qu'il
n'aimait rôdeuse et qu'actuellement
krasniqi effectivement en pleine forme
mais pour être sûr il faudrait faire
d'un vrai tournoi avec les cochrane
ricanant déchire of faire un quadruples
ronde même des matchs je suis par les
deux matches des qualifications non non
je crois qu'il parlait d'un billet de
qualification alors que tournoi avec
quatre joueurs qui jouerait donc 4 x 3
12 parties c'est-à-dire quatre partis
qui comptent chacun - vraiment go un
groupe pro c'est ce qu'on comprend cesse
mis en place donc pour déterminer qui
est le numéro 2 mondial
mais que de toute façon pour l'instant
il est bien installé à la première place
voilà en tout cas il revient toujours
sur sept se sont sauvés de revoir un
cycle champion du monde à l'ancienne
formule en tout cas moi et tout à fait
ma vie donc bon effectivement il a dit
que cramique montée en puissance et que
ça ça le motive et justement puisque il
fallait bien que ça pousse parce que lui
il n'avait plus trop de raisons de se
motiver
donc d'où la deuxième question de la
deuxième question que comment fais-tu
gary pour pour rester au top
réponse très simple j'aime le jeu j'aime
analyser j'aime beaucoup travailler avec
mon second temps il y aurait de quoi
yann avec les oreilles avec mes
ordinateurs puisque on dirait que c'est
des amis
il aime beaucoup les ordinateurs ce qui
est donc provoquer une nouvelle question
est ce que tu penses que l'ordinateur va
être plus fort que toi est ce que tu
penses que c'est ton unique adversaire
actuellement et là la réponse a été un
peu comment dire biaisé puisque il a dit
qu'il aimait page de compte les
ordinateurs enfin il a dit qu'il
trouvait intéressant de jouer contre
l'ordinateur mais là il a posé des
conditions à condition qu'il soit
complètement supervisé cet ordinateur
dont qui est effectivement pas de
polémique possible comme il y en a eu
pour les matchs contre ibm contre le
deep blue enfin tout cas polémique après
le match ils se posaient des questions
sur qui pouvait intervenir sur cette
machine mais que donc finalement en fait
il pense que les gens et il a peut-être
raison on préfère voir des joueurs
humains s'affrontaient ce que peut-être
la beauté comme dit nicolas giffard la
beauté net échec c'est peut-être les
fautes plus que mario est tout à fait ça
rejoint ce qu'a dit nicolas giffard
garry kasparov pense que les combats de
chair et de sang comme il les appelle
seront mieux pour le pour le public pour
le fun puisque y aura des fautes et des
erreurs
maintenant au niveau de la préparation
pour le tournoi ça n'a pas été facile
puisque
linarès était annoncée très tard il est
pris des engagements pour la période qui
précédait le tournoi donc cette
préparation est un peu parti un peu
collapse comme il dit et surtout il
avait prévu donc pour ce faire un peu de
publicité pour son site club kasparov
il avait prévu de faire un grand prix
sur internet la même période que lynn
harris puisqu'il avait pas de
confirmation et que ça va chambouler
tous ses plans mais il a quand même
décidé d'aller à linares pas ce que
c'était c'était la condition pour que le
temps ait lieu et qu'il fallait qu'il
garry kasparov pour les sponsors
donc il voulait pas être le joueur qui
annule linares donc il a été joué là-bas
et sachant bien que chaque fois qu'il
passait un tour à son grand prix hyper d
un demi point linares et donc il a quand
même joué jouer ce tournoi maintenant
sur les projets de garry kasparov c'est
la dernière question comment il sera
dans vingt ans alors ils n'arrivent pas
à se projeter aussi loin et mais par
contre pour les deux prochaines années à
venir il va développer les échecs sur
internet
il va rester très actif il va rester
numéro 1 encore au moins quatre ans et
il est en train d'écrire un livre sur
son match contre le monde est également
un livre sur les championnats du monde
et c'est justement là qu'il commence à
parler de lui à la troisième personne
pour dire que garry kasparov va
développer le jeu d'échecs et que et que
son nom restera dans l'histoire
voilà donc une garry kasparov plein
d'énergie on a vu que une question de
trois secondes amène une réponse de deux
minutes ce qui fait donc
c'est très bien en tout cas mais c'était
très bien notamment qu'il avait fait
beaucoup d'interviews avance et celle ci
puisqu'il est fait à conférence de
presse il avait ensuite d'autres
interviews et des télévisions russes
donc il a accordé sept son énergie pour
cette interview on en est très heureux
voilà des notions dans l'énergie puisque
vous pourrez suivre maintenant diagonale
en anglais à partir de lundi prochaine
toutes les semaines sur avec michael
caine donc en direct à partir de 16h30
je crois donc le dise ça sera archivé
aussi est aussi diagonale la leçon il
voit avec bertrand billard lundi matin à
10h30 pour la deuxième oui là pour les
lève tôt mais bon les missions et bien
entendu archives et donc à 10h30 avec
bertrand guyard et moi même diagonale
des leçons j'apprends les échecs
événements à venir voilà donc à voir et
à revoir au revoir